this weekend a country rapper is opening
for some of hip-hop's biggest names
justin champagne has over 50 million
streams on spotify and 41 million views
on youtube his new ep if she ain't
country it's out today and you can see
him tomorrow night at michelob ultra
arena and he joins us now good to see
you buddy congratulations on the new ep
i listened to it on the way to the tv
station here today how would you
describe your sound
uh it's definitely different for sure
it's like
i guess like the the word i use is like
a big gumbo you know what i mean it's
just like rock hip-hop
country
i don't know
everything there's rap there's
everything
how did you connect with snoop dogg we
saw the the tick tock there how did that
connection happen yeah so that was well
so that was actually after the show okay
uh the video
um but connecting wise was
management-wise and um
he said he was down for us to come open
up so there we go so we've been on the
road with him for these last couple of
weeks do you have any snoop dogg stories
so tomorrow you have snoop dogg ice cube
warren g yourself at mandalay bay have
any stories with these guys
uh i mean
then we can tell on uh cbs television
one but you can kind of imagine how
where that went you know
he's snoop you have some fun right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah listening to your ep where do you
get your inspiration for the songs that
you write because the one that that
grabbed me uh was slow down listening
actually to driving here today it's like
an anthem i can see myself i'm getting
pumped up listening to it where's the
inspiration come from writing these
songs so that particular song man it was
more like when i wrote the record um it
was more like the hate that i have i
guess
and the love that i have you know what i
mean so it was more like just kind of
reaching out and giving that attention
which i usually don't ever do but uh i
just felt like i had to let him know
that i hear him talking you know what i
mean and um but that's where kind of
when i talk about the hometown the hate
in the hometown and all that so it's
kind of like the um the negativity kind
of just showing that you're not slowing
down you're you're still going you found
your rhythm and you're still going you
have a line in there instead of fighting
your demons you're married
you keep going yeah just keep going
nothing's stopping me nothing's gonna
stop you man you're the rising star
right now what's so far i mean you're
new to the game but you're rising to the
top so fast what's been the best part
about about being a singer
the experience yeah with everything just
it's always something new and it's like
it's it's never it's never a dull moment
it's like hey we just did the song cool
now here's a video all right now here's
the show all right now here's this
interview all right and you just keep
going it's just non-stop but i mean
just uh it's just been a blessing you
know what i mean so that's what i love
about it you know just to have the
opportunity to do this for a living
perfect we have the same initials jc so
thank you so much for joining us have
fun tomorrow night it's been a great
show mickel up ultra arena ticket's
still available no it's sold out it's
sold out